you've practiced some of the most
elegant formalism in computer science
and yet you're the creator of a concept
like literate programming which seems to
move closer to natural language type of
description of programming yep yeah
absolutely so how do you see those two
as conflicting as the formalism of
theory and the idea of literate
programming so there we are in a non
uniform system like I don't think one
one size fits all and I don't think and
I don't think all truth lies in one in
one kind of expertise and so somehow in
a way you'd say my what my life is a
convex combination of English and
mathematics and you're okay with that
and not only that I think thriving I
wish you know I want my kids to be that
way I want cetera not used left-brain
right-brain at the same time you got a
lot more done that's that was part of it
and I've heard that you didn't really
read for pleasure until into your 30s
literature it's true you know more about
me than I do but I'll try to be
consistent with what you're really ya
know just believe me yeah just go with
whatever story I tell you it'll be
easier that way the conversation so I've
heard mentioned a Philip Roth's American
pastoral which I love as a book I don't
know if it was it was mentioned as
something I think that was meaningful to
you as well you need a case what
literary books had a lasting impact on
you what literature okay good so I met
Roth already well we both got doctors
from Harvard on the same day so so we
were yeah we had lunch together and
stuff like that and but he knew that you
know computer books would never sell
well well all right so you say you you
you you're a teenager when you left
Russia so I I have to say that Tolstoy
was one of the
influences on me I especially like Anna
Karenina not because of a particular
area of the plot of the story where but
because there's this character who you
know did the philosophical discussions
it's all it's a whole way of life is
worked out there it's among the
characters until again and so it that I
thought was was especially beautiful on
the other hand does the FCI I didn't
like at all because I I felt that he his
genius was mostly because he kept
forgetting what he what he had started
out to do and he was just sloppy I
didn't think that that it did that he
polished his stuff at all and I tend to
admire somebody who who Todd's the i's
and cross the t's so that the music of
the prose this way you admire more end
the I certainly do admire the music of
the language which I couldn't appreciate
in the Russian original but but I can in
Victor Hugo because close friendships
like his closer but Tolstoy I like the
same reason I like Herman Wouk as a as a
novelist I that I think I like his book
Marjorie Morningstar has a similar
character in Hugo who developed his own
personal philosophy and exponent and it
called goes in the ending was consistent
yeah right and it's worth worth
pondering uh so yeah like Nietzsche and
like what you don't like Friedrich
Nietzsche or age yeah no no you're like
this has like I keep seeing quotations
for Nietzsche and and you never tempt me
to read any further please full of
contradictions we will certainly not
appreciate and but Schiller you know I'm
trying to get the cross what I
appreciate in literature and part of it
is the it is as you say the music of the
language the way it flows
and take Raymond Chandler versus
dashiell hammett Dashiell Hammett's
sentences are awful and Raymond
Chandler's are beautiful they just flow
so I I don't I don't read literature
because it's supposed to be good for me
or because somebody said it's great but
but I could find things that I like I
mean you mentioned you addressed like
James Bond so like I know I love Ian
Fleming I think he's got a he had a
really great gift for if he has a golf
game or game of bridge or something and
this comes into a story it'll it'll be
the most exciting golf game or or you
know the absolute best possible hands of
bridge that that exist in and any he
exploits and tells it beautifully as
well so in connecting some things here
looking at literate programming and
being able to convey encode algorithms
to a computer in a way that mimics how
humans speak how what do you think about
natural language in general and the
messiness of our human world about
trying to express yeah difficult things
so the idea of literate programming is
to is really to try to understand
something better by seeing it from at
least two perspectives the formal and
the informal if we try to understand a
complicated thing if we can look at it
in different ways and so this is in fact
the key to technical writing a good
technical writer trying not to be
obvious about it but says everything
twice formally and informally or maybe
three times but you try to give the
reader a way to put the concept into his
own brain or her own brain is that
better for the writer or the reader or
both
well the writer just tries to understand
the reader that's the goal of a writer
is to have a good mental image of the
reader and to say what the reader
expects next and to to impress the
reader with what has impressed the
writer why something is interesting so
when you have a computer program we try
to instead of looking at it as something
that we're just trying to give an
instruction to the computer what we
really want to be is giving giving
insight to the person who's going to be
maintaining this program or to the
programmer himself when he's debugging
it as to why this stuff is being done
and so all the techniques of exposition
that a teacher uses or book writers make
you better program or if you're if your
program is going to be not just a
one-shot deal so how difficult is that
do you see hope for the combination of
informal and formal for the programming
tasks yeah I I'm the wrong person to ask
I guess because I'm a geek but but I
think for a geek it's easy I don't know
I don't know not some people have
difficulty writing and that might be
because there's something in their brain
structure that makes it hard for them to
write or or it might be something just
that they haven't had enough practice
I'm not the right one to to judge but I
don't think you teach any person any
particular skill like I do think that
that writing is is half of my life and
so I put it together in letter program
even right even when I'm writing a
one-shot program I I write it in
literate way because I get it right
faster though now does it get compiled
automatically or so I guess on the
technical side my question was how
difficult is a design a system where
much of the programming is done
informally informally yeah informally
I think whatever works to make it
understandable is good but then you have
to also understand how informal is you
have to know the limitations you have to
connect so so by putting the formal and
informal together this this is where
this is where it gets locked into your
into your brain now you can you can say
informally well I'm working on a problem
right now so let's go there I get that
can you give me an example of of
connecting the informal in the formal
well it's a little too complicated an
example there's a puzzle that that's
self referential it's called a Japanese
arrow puzzle and and and you're given a
a bunch of boxes each one points north
east south or west and at the end you're
supposed to fill in each box with the
number of distinct numbers that it
points to so if I put a three in a box
that means that and its point to five
other boxes that means that there's
going to be three different numbers in
those five boxes and and those boxes are
pointing what I might be pointing to me
one of my might be pointing the other
the other way but anyway I could try a
pencil to find a set of numbers that
obeys this complicated condition that
each number counts how many distinct
numbers if it points do well and still a
guy sent me his solution to this problem
where he where he presents formal
statements that that say either this is
true or this is true or this is true and
and and so I try to render that formal
statement informally and I try say I
contain a three and and the guys I'm
pointing to contain the numbers one two
and six so by putting it in formally and
also converted into a
into a dialogue statement that helps me
understand the logical statement that
he's written down as a string of numbers
in terms of some abstract variables that
he had
you